[Applause]
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic guy
remember it so you don't have to and
welcome to another rendition of wtr aka
what's that real this is where we look
at TV that was forgotten by some but
remember by others for just how strange
they were with that said we all love dr.
Seuss is timeless characters of The Cat
in the Hat and the Grinch
so much so that some people even watch
this but did you know there is
a time when they actually did a
crossover it's gone by a couple names
over the years the Grinch Grinch is the
Cat in the Hat The Cat in the Hat gets
cringed which both sound like children's
intros to sexual harassment but whatever
one called it when I was growing up was
the Grinch versus the cat because really
that's what it is it's two popular
characters in the same universe finally
meeting up and well surviving each other
it seems kind of strange for dr. Seuss
who didn't really do crossover battles
because stuff would usually be
associated with something like save a
Marvel production well funny you should
think that because this actually was
made by Marvel productions yeah soon The
Lorax and said I am are gonna fight over
the warring nations of the Sneetches and
the who's with a cameo by spider-man
we've all been waiting for this was
advertised everywhere when it came on TV
and to its credit it's really not a bad
idea it's kind of like Batman vs
Superman yeah you're funny
there you go where there's two seemingly
opposite protagonists who also seem to
have a lot in common both are agents of
anarchy
they like to disrupt the status quo and
take people out of their comfort zones
the reasons though is what makes them
enemies one does it to lighten the mood
and open up possibilities while the
other does it to ruin the mood and limit
possibilities even the lessons have a
different spin with the Cat in the Hat
he's the one dispensing the moral with
the Grinch he's the one learning of the
moral so it seems like there was just
enough in common and just enough
different to make this really really
good right well as much as I've praised
Seuss in the past even I have to admit
not everything was perfect nothing was
awful but some ideas were better as just
that ideas and for what it's worth this
seem to have a lot of ideas especially
for kids it just didn't seem to have a
lot of focus again a tough combination
as Kenton the Hat was a somewhat random
in archaic story where Grinch had a very
solid beginning middle and end which
makes this a very tricky combination The
Grinch as well was already used twice
with a Halloween special after the
Christmas debut but didn't exactly get
the strongest reaction so was tough to
figure out if he could work in other
tales outside of his first one the story
The Grinch waits to the voice of a
Smuckers jelly guy describing the
morning bed with a smile and hello
I could kill kids with a pitchfork and
you'd still love my voice however the
Grinch goes back to his evil ways one is
mere yells at him yeah like I said kind
of odd mirror convinces him to go out
and cause trouble and this is where he
literally bumps into the cabin the Hat
who makes the apparent mistake of
calling him green face any inconvenience
a letís that I may have caused you mr.
green face mr. green face that is our
word
so the Grinch decides to chase him down
create a machine that messes with
reality and just kind of annoy him it's
kind of a downgrade compared to his
other adventures first he wants to rob
people the joys of giving that he wants
to terrified the world with fear from
hellish looking monsters now he's just
kind of a troll in fact you could argue
he's literally the world's first
internet troll think about it he uses
his computer to hack your everyday life
to mildly annoy you and he's the only
one that finds it funny at all
yes he's sort of a pioneer of
obnoxiousness what do you think about it
[Music]
I'll admit it's a little odd to see the
Cat in the Hat constantly duped and get
more and more frustrated as it goes on
it's Kelly seeing Groucho Marx get mad
or radical Edward get mad or the
roadrunner get mad
there's just some creations you always
think are going to be comfortable and in
control of their world
which makes it a little off-putting when
you see they don't always have the smart
answer it really cracks me up when he
flat-out calls the Grinch a psychopath
how funny is that there's a dr. Seuss
story where somebody uses the word
psychopath
that's insane or psychopathic I guess to
be fair though only a psychopath will
change the pronunciation words to make
them rhyme the sounds that you make all
the sounds of my choice I can make you
sound better or make you sound worse
sinner all yours feeling pretty good is
too cat in the hood good and why are you
changing that they already right this
all comes to a head when the Grinch uses
his machine to mess with a restaurant
for really no reason than to give soos
an excuse to say he took LSD for
inspiration
yep this is another dr. Seuss trip out
scene that doesn't connect too much but
who cares it's a dr. Seuss trip out see
I will totally endorse getting a minor
drunk if it leads to another pink
elephant sequence it's true priorities I
want to trip out man look at this he's
going against the lesson of his own
books green eggs are okay but polkadot
eggs shut that but to be fair maybe
the cat that has frustration ties into
the kinda-sorta message yeah even the
moral is a little hard to grasp but I
still can't say it's really wrong in any
way amongst his frustration he finally
realizes that the way to win is not
killing by anger but killing by kindness
he goes to the Grinch's house and
reminds him of his mother
[Music]
thank God he happened to have a good
relationship with her because it
eventually softens him up and makes him
good again he even has an inner
monologue with her which the more I
think about it strange what happens a
lot in this half of a special is
technically just people talking to
themselves
everyone's a psychopath so I guess the
message centers around power of
motherhood to always bring family into
everything that a person's weakness is
in their heart it's confusing
nevertheless it is still a kinda nice
it'll be an unfocused scene leading to a
relatively harmless ending and that's
really the best way I can describe this
special nice unfocused but harmless it's
certainly not Susa strongest work and
truth be told it could have been a bit
more interesting but it still needs
seeing two of his most famous characters
meet and interact off each other what
the story's not the best it still feels
like this is what the characters would
do and say if they ever did run into one
another so it's kind of fun to watch if
only for that reason yeah it's pointless
yeah it doesn't always make sense but
sometimes that's okay it's still
creative still strange and still
unmistakably soos you can still get it
on DVD and witness all the goofiness or
psychotic tendencies yourself give it a
buy and see one of the most surreal
crossovers ever devised
I'm the Nostalgia Critic I remember so
you don't have to coming next week it's
scooby-doo two monsters unleashed the
death of Alicia Silverstone's career but
you can see it now under vessel's ad
free early access just three dollars a
month to see tons of people's videos
early as well as a bunch of other extra
features check it out and get the early
scoop
[Music]
[Applause]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shada and this week we're doing one you
might not think about that much but is
still very very important the guy Dog
Foundation this organization has been
around since 1946 and their mission is
simple to provide guide dogs and
training free of charge to people who
are blind or visually impaired for 70
years the Guide Dog Foundation has
trained and placed guide and service
dogs to provide increased independence
enhanced mobility and companionship to
people who are blind have low vision or
have other disabilities once they make
the decision to get an assistance dog
applicants become a part of the
foundation's open and welcoming
community they're supported with an
uncompromised commitment from highly
empathetic and certified trainers they
pair each student with the dog that's
right for them and the power of their
bond makes the strongest of friendships
crossing the street independently
becomes a moment of liberation and trust
traveling alone becomes a welcomed
adventure embracing new experiences
becomes an everyday occurrence it costs
over fifty thousand dollars to breed
raise train and place one assistance dog
however all of the foundation services
are provided at no charge to the
individual funding comes from the
generosity of people like you
corporations foundations businesses and
many more so definitely take a look
watch some of their videos and see how
you can help give sight to someone who
needs it the most
[Music]
you